well we thought I thought it couldn't
get worse but then it did get worse with
a you're a next recommendation okay I
want to preface this is not a
recommendation it's not a recommendation
right I I
this show we're really going into this
one this show already this show I I
never felt more betrayed by a show in my
life yeah so straight up what was your
category uh it was name a MILF hentai
you didn't like yes yeah and uh what was
the name of this one again I forgot it
was uh Sleepless uh mid-summer
mid-summer so I yeah okay first of all
uh that's that's what it made me off
yeah I'm definitely Sleepless I'm gonna
be real I watched this one uh most most
hints I watch I don't have subtitles
right yeah so a lot of the times I'm
missing out in the fine details I hear a
lot but then at this one I went back to
re-watch because I was really confused
why it went the direction it did what
the story is yeah yeah but so here was
my understanding of the story
um before I kind of got to episode two
and this is what I was excited for it
because I was high so it opens with a
kid getting attacked it's all burned in
my memory by the way yeah remember it
opens up the kid getting in the taxi and
he's like you know he's in like the
middle of nowhere kind of in Japan
because the cab driver is like all right
take me to this manner he's like bro the
MILF the Milkman it is literally a
[__] milk I'm like he's like bro you
straight away with the MILF manner a lot
of people don't come out when they go
there he's like take me to the MILF
Manor
henceforth go
what other what other words
faster so he gets the mansion and it's
it's pretty high it's pretty [__]
high the first episode hype bro it's
great so it's like the first episode you
meet this maid she's great yeah really
attractive yeah uh they go in the Onsen
together get a little frisky yeah it's
great they didn't I love it I love it
when hentai when they don't do sex right
away yeah I love it when they have an
interaction yeah and it doesn't lead to
sex yeah I'm like classic it's like
little tease you made me you made me
stick around yeah
also one thing I really really liked
about this hentai like initially is that
it has a very very different art style
that doesn't look like every other
pieces so much because I feel like a lot
of hentai right now has gotten so
homogeneous right in terms of their
character designs you know it's everyone
looks like the same copy paste everyone
has like a [__] buffer on their skin
to make it extra shiny
yeah this one looks really unique a
really unique it was I feel like it was
like a nice mix of like kind of the 90s
hentai Style with like a modern style
yeah like mixed in yeah every character
in this Mansion was just like a 10 out
of 10. dude right right yeah I mean like
the first one my favorite was the maid
yeah yeah and we had a scene right away
with the maid and I was like yes yeah I
loved it because she was kind of like I
mean I guess if I have to yeah yeah
indifferent and I always think that's
you know I don't know why I like that
but yeah it's kind of hot yeah and it
was fun and they didn't and she's like
no I'm not gonna have sex with you and I
was like
we'll get to that because like I was I
was very very much enjoying the first
episode yeah but in the scene with the
mum I was just like something made you
feel uneasy something made me feel
uneasy and I was just like I've seen a
lot of [__] scenes before an anime
but why does she keep like sucking his
dick kind of like a straw that's weird
yeah that's weird yeah I was like maybe
it's like a maybe maybe it's just uh
maybe it's a finish yeah maybe it's a
finish the thing that made me a little
uneasy was that
um they have this spray which is
actually just Viagra spread yeah
sure PP recover after you know doing it
and I was like oh yeah well I'm sure
they're just like having sex a lot yeah
yeah and it was great because we've got
plenty of scenes and the mom was great
mom was super I loved her just yeah in
general I wish she was real that was
great it was good seeing hi dude you
cannot believe uh how hyped I was for
episode two and I because I watched this
when it came out right literally like
Day Zero I was there
I was refreshing Connor was at the
midnight screening I was waiting was it
the midnight screening with the other
comments right we were all hype we were
like we're all shaking hands in our
suits like great another successful
Milford it's been months since we've had
a good mil fan literally it had been it
had been and I cannot preface this
enough 2022 had literally no good MILF
hentai at all there was like there was
like one or two tops that were passable
right and this finally felt like we were
getting one we were getting this the
golden MILF experience this is what
we've been waiting for real yeah
it was like MILF MILF Mana IRL get that
[__] out of here we finally got a real
one yeah and then I waited after three
months episode two finally came out you
can imagine how excited I was you can
imagine boy you can imagine how excited
I was and then what I saw what happened
when I saw what they did I couldn't
believe it
I never felt so disgusted
this not only did it not live up to my
expectations like Masterpiece three
which is already I will get into that
later yeah but it was like they they
took a 180. I I'm so I'm so disgusted
from MILF Manor to just some of the most
like just it was sore yeah it was sore
it uh I would say it was closer to
hostel because there unfortunately there
was no way this guy was gonna came out
um we watched Euphoria I'm not gonna lie
I think this one was even grosser for me
you know what I kind of agree I it's
it's it's definitely on that same yeah
yeah this just hurt more because I was
also invested like I was I was I was
there this is like if if like I was like
a Mario Kart fan I found out that like I
don't know like Mario like kills
everyone after the race dude I feel I've
never been click baited by Hindi so hard
no did you when I when I explained this
to you guys it could because I warned
them I was like dude it gets gross and I
was like and I was like it's it's Connor
I've seen euphoria
to set the scene to set the scene
um I'm gonna explain this like a doctor
uh to set the scene how we episode one
ends on a cliffhanger and it's great
because he's done the maid he's done the
MILF yeah and then now he gets to do the
daughter okay and now it's now it's like
uh now it's like a cliffhanger it's like
oh what a what what how's the daughter
gonna be she seems like she has a little
bit of an attitude
I was okay with like not really
exploring her because I really want my
film Yeah Yeah my two favorites yeah
yeah we got it yeah yeah
um and then so you load up episode two
you're like okay let's see where this
goes um and then starts off pretty
starts pretty okay you know she sprays
some more spray on his dick and she's
talking him a bit weird talk to him
talks to a little bit weird you liked
something seems a bit off but I'm sure
I'm sure uh I'm sure it's just normal I
know I think the family's just weird
um and then she brings out this
contraption
she uh brings out this contraption and
she says I want to drink some tapioca
milk tea That's what she says oh yes I I
forgot him she's like I'm thirsty she
she is thirsty and she wants to drink
some milk tea so she brings out this
contraption which is a syringe with some
tapioca in it and some liquid in it uh
with a long tube and then proceeds to
shove the tube up the guys you know what
and I'm not talking about his ass
I believe the uh I believe the
scientific term for it is called
sounding
I think that's the term for it if you
know what that means you know what that
means so it is uh it is
it it says
urethra yeah that and then she injects
the Boba yeah and then she proceeds to
inject the Boba and the liquid
into into this
um and
yeah that uh that that is that is when
you see all the details of it going in
and just and she drinks it afterwards by
making a knot with Boba I guess in yeah
and the dialogue is just it's awful it
is engine juicy like after after he like
gets it out of his system
she's like I want a little uh fresh milk
with this one yes and he proceeds to
climax into the glass and she's just
casually sipping on this thing and I'm
like bro what is wrong I I I'll admit
right I I I'm gonna say I like it just
in case you worry about that um I was
like maybe maybe that's just the one
gross thing that happens I'm gonna skip
past this and it just got worse and then
when the maid comes in oh I don't even
think let's say let's say the maid comes
in uh there is a banana which the maid
is forced to put somewhere and then
let's say maybe he had a bit of Taco
Bell the night before and then and then
that comes out
very important detail the banana goes in
a place and then the dude has to help
push the banana in with his people okay
okay for what okay I I was I was
grasping onto anything that I could like
hang on to for like me to take my mind
off the situation and thankfully like I
was like this is there is no way this
banana is keeping its shape this dude
shoves this banana in with his uh with
his pee pee and it perfectly maintains
its shape during everything
obviously right after you've had a
Tapioca drink you eat a banana sundae to
wash it down a banana chocolate sun and
so that's what comes out and um they
they eat it and then you're like oh my
God and then somebody like well that's
at least the worst is over oh it doesn't
get what it certainly gets worse yeah
because in the next scene they just go
to an operating table oh yeah so there's
a secret room in this manner that in
episode one it's behind this white door
and the maid says to the guy whatever
you do don't enter through this white
door it's it's a secret room but
obviously when when that gets pushed
down your throat
you get a little curious and so one
night he wakes up after he's force-fed
this banana chocolate smoothie he wakes
up and he he in a stupor he goes oh I'm
gonna go check out this room
and uh goes down into a [__] sassas
basement and there's just like test
tubes yeah there are disenbembered
um penises and tits just uh just
floating about I I don't know like uh
this is this is a very weird support
it's like I I was on board and I don't
know who this second episode's for like
Psychopaths clearly I think it was to
[__] over people like me I think I think
they wanted to [__] and ruin they would
definitely just trolling I think they
wanted the troll people yeah I I said
the last hentai I think was made to
limit test erections uh I think the
person that made this just has a
vendetta against it right yeah I think
they won I I like if anyone nut into
this I genuinely am concerned yeah yeah
it's because like the thing the thing
that makes this so bad is just how much
detail they put into these scenes like I
remember that that first scene with the
tube I could feel the entire male
population entire just like I like
collectively grabbed a crotch area and
go oh and I remember as well like when
she's like when she's putting it in she
goes don't squirm or I might make a hole
somewhere else and I'm like ah yeah
you're like like I'm pretty sure one
like Yoda said he fills the disturbance
in the force this like they were
animating this scene you know this when
we think like how are we allowed to show
that but we're not allowed to show a
dick
you're pushing it again like what is
this
just the double standards it's like I I
could not explain how angry I was and
how ashamed I was and then the final
scene right where he I turned it off by
this point oh okay so I I sat through it
to the end because I was like how could
this get any worse
so basically what happens is he gets not
he so he sneaks into the the test tube
room right and he's like oh God I gotta
get the [__] out of here as he's about
to escape from the room a mysterious
Shadow like comes in knocks him out he
wakes up on the operating table and he's
he's fully naked and he is inside the
mom
and he's like wait something feels
strange about this and she goes yeah
don't worry about it we replaced your PP
with a much better PP
the much better PP is what I can only
describe
oh wait I remember that as a extremely
flaccid 15 feet long tentacle looking
[__] that just like slithers out
okay
was it like a completely different color
as well that was a completely different
color they gave him a black [__]
and it's a comically large black I just
I think my I think I think mine mine was
broken at this point because I just
full-on started my first hour
I thought I didn't read it as that I
thought it was like a a decrepit dick
that is like it was like gone from like
uh bro it was so soft I'm like how did
that thing stay here it is it is so
comically large it is basically like a
horse [__] they gave him a black guy
it's bigger than a horse [__] man I just
this thing slithers out like a snake
and he's just like what have you done to
my [__] and we've like
we've turned it it's all pacifier we've
improved it yeah we've built it stronger
like better like you know when people
have those arguments they're like man we
shouldn't change things in anime because
we shouldn't censor because it's part of
the culture I'm like [__] like this is
like absolutely not 100 we should censor
this stuff yeah what are you talking
about did she it is [__] and then and
then as well the final final scene is
like the main and the the mom or the
daughter I don't know at this point all
three of the the ladies are just In
Cahoots yeah yeah yeah and and of course
they have to insert a straw and into the
end of his peepee again and just being
like just like like they're sharing a
[__] like cocktail on them a very
long straw it is but considering how
massive this uh this horse penis is they
got one of the crazy straws
they made this how do you get someone to
sit there and animate that like these
animators are chat I wanted to be in the
boardroom when this was pitched I just
can't believe it episode one about
everyone was on board they're like yeah
that's a resounding success gentlemen
we've done it again and then this one
was just like what and then and then the
director went on a [__] Coke bin he
just came back and he was like this
they've got an idea like there's no way
they they they made this and people did
not need to go to therapy after it like
yeah I refuse to believe you could
animate this and not have like
consequences oh yeah
this was this is the first time where
I'm like oh this is this is what nsfl is
like this is this is this is not safe
this is not safe for life
um
it's just the thing that shocks me is at
least with other like messed up hentai
that I've seen at least with other shows
you get that tone from episode one no
this was yeah
I don't I don't read the tags when I
watch anime yeah I just click on it and
scroll through right yeah
um and and yeah so I was I was great I
was man I can't get over how the
portrayed I was yeah oh yeah I saw
backstabbed man you know like sometimes
when I watch like those Netflix
documentaries about people getting like
betrayed or screwed over by someone I'm
like man I've never never felt that way
but this way made me feel it yeah
because like when you when you
recommended this to me and I saw that it
wasn't that's not the word well when you
suggested this show to me I'm gonna put
this right out of there when you
suggested to me with the pretense of
this is a milf hentai that Conor didn't
like right yeah and I watched episode
one and I was like wow his standards
have gone up oh my
and then episode two kicked in I'm like
ah yeah now I understand yeah there is I
felt bad that I'd make you guys watch
that yeah yeah it was it was a horrible
day to have eyes it was nice because I
felt like I got to share a trauma at
least for my friends so that's nice I
can all go to therapy together now we
all understand the pain and the
suffering I just unfortunately I don't
think we can go to a nonsense again
because I think my dick has Now inverted
back into my body oh it definitely did
yeah it does not want to come out yeah
absolutely
chastity belt is on now I don't want to
anymore and I'm a good we are good
Christian boys now we do not watch him
just like man we didn't have a single
good MILF hentai last year yeah no
Banger and that's what yeah and that's
all we got episode one was the best we
got yeah and then and then it ends with
uh another
unsuspecting kids being like take me to
the mill like take me to the MILF house
I want to go to the MILF house and now
we know if someone asks you to take you
to the MILF house no matter how good
that sounds you say no yeah that's why
I'm not watching MILF Manor I just I
just I'm destroyed anyway
holy [__] but I just is there anything
else we want to say oh come on can we
can we wipe this one yeah I want to get
rid of this yeah first time where I'm
jealous of Men In Black where I can just
[__] yeah this is what I want right
yeah yes